Oprah Winfrey will be in Brooklyn this
weekend for the latest stop on her
wellness tour she's spreading an
inspirational message this time with
special guests Michelle Obama but she's
also dealing with some controversy which
she discussed with our lead national
correspondent David beg no over the
novel American dirt her book club
selection that she announced right here
on CBS this morning last month the
author of that novel is Janine Cummings
she's white and she's been accused of
insensitivity and her depiction of the
Mexican migrant experience I think
publishers are thinking differently I
know I certainly am thinking differently
I certainly want to include for myself a
realm of Latin X experiences that I have
not had before and so I think it's a
moment that we get to move forward I
want to take all of the controversy from
both sides bring them together in a
conversation that helps us move on and
David joins us at the table so Oprah
says it's a moment it clearly is she's
got a lot to tell you it sounds like
yeah look she was very open in saying I
want to bring them together let's do a
special it's gonna air on Apple TV Plus
in March she said early on I hear you
and what you're saying matters so let's
have a larger discussion about it we of
course were with her because the big
Brooklyn shows this weekend it's sold
out Anthony I knew you wanted to I'm not
surprised
maybe not go get one started working on
this story you may be surprised to hear
this as well but the city of New York
offers all three hundred and eighty
thousand of its employees a wellness
program and they partnered with W W
formerly known as Weight Watchers which
Oprah's a major investor in city
employees get a more than fifty percent
discount if they join in and it provides
a squad of reinforcements that really
support everyone who's on a journey to
live well this morning you're gonna meet
some members of that squad lieutenant
Tara Deckard is a ringleader by day she
commands the NYPD grand larceny
divisions Intelligence Unit but she's
got an undercover passion and it plays
out underground
that's where the NYPD has its fitness
center and where lieutenant Deckard
shreds calories her weight rap sheet has
dropped 60 pounds I had high blood
pressure I was seven hearts I'm keeping
up with the kids because I was
overweight and I said I've had enough
I've been all the way since I was five
years old it was time to change she
started eating right and started a WW
group inside police headquarters our
group has lost over 3,000 pounds that's
the weight of a police car yesterday
lieutenant Decker joined a wellness walk
with two of her WW accomplices
Danielle Craven who lost 75 pounds and
Shaira gilma Gainey in all 2080 two NYPD
employees have shred more than 8,000
pounds it is all part of a unique
partnership the work well NYC program
launched with w w back in June of 2016
nearly 40,000 city employees have
collectively lost more than 170,000
pounds all three ladies are about to be
in a lineup it's the kind of line if you
want to hear of Saturday at the Barclays
Center in Brooklyn but yesterday there
was a surprise Oprah joined in on the
walk finish this the tour thus far has
taught me taught me that there is unity
in the country around the issue of
wellness that everybody wants the same
thing they want a better life for
themselves so that they can be better
for their children and their families
when you hear about some election IRA
losing a hundred and forty pounds I told
her that used to be my goal weight I was
pre-diabetic before all of that now done
and yeah I was I didn't tell you that
keep the secrets over and I was
pre-diabetic before WWE
no longer I know I know my eyes are
glowing I just checked with my doctor I
think that's the Oprah exclusive y'all
lookin on where shimira Tara and
Danielle you guys have all worked so
hard and it's it's so it was such a
special moment for them you know she
Myra really talked about keeping it off
so her daughter was eight years old at
that moment she was putting on shamira
socks she's 20 today and she IRA has not
yo-yoed she has maintained the weight
loss that's great that's a really
impressive women this morning and right
art segment and here we've done amazing
work yeah losing one of more than a
squad car collectively and Anthony I'm
sorry you can't go to the Wellness Tour
event this weekend my mom's got a ticket
she's got two friends with her my aunts
coming over as well it's like it's a
full house we got the air mattress out
in the next 12 hours they good this
won't work at home to get ready welcome
mom well I'll see what I can do have a
cousin that's actually on the tour she's
one of the dancers yes all right David
thank you